hey what's up guys it's Eric here joined
with Justin thanks so much for joining
us for the stream if there's other
awesome blizzard and overwatch content
you want to watch stay tuned to the
GameSpot channel but right now today
we're gonna be checking out some cool
hearthstone stuff all right let's do it
all right so here we go see what this
first one is so satisfying it always is
sorry night changing so I haven't really
been studying these cards as much mm-hmm
I just know you want to lift King
probably and there's like that dog
legendary or another just small pro tip
for you guys if you guys go through the
prologue which will take you about 10
minutes and is available for everybody
you'll actually get a legendary hero
card it's random right one of the one of
the several heroes I got the rogue I
believe which one did you get Destin I
got Garrosh so I got the warrior okay
but you so you're guaranteed in that one
to get a legendary hero so a legendary
death knight but if you want to get that
full set you definitely wanna you want
to do your card packs first because
you're gonna get another legendary hero
yeah but you want to of course try to do
that first so that you don't duplicate
up your legendary hero right obviously
because that's like kind of like one of
the new changes you get duplicates of
legendary heroes or like legendary cards
until you're done with a full set
correct and the other changes they made
to this one is that in the first ten
cards of any pack you are guaranteed to
get a legend what is it are Benedictus
shuffle a copy of your opponent's deck
into your think that's it like that's
such an interesting effect but I I tend
to play rush decks so I don't know if
that's gonna be as likely so in that
priests I I don't want to I don't want
to drag this stuff out a whole other
death in my deck
as you mentioned was it you say first
ten packs of a new expansion you get a
legendary now yes so the first ten packs
of you will within better with a five or
whether you've earned them those first
ten packs you're gonna have one
legendary so that might be it we may be
done get legendary and could be done
here so I know it doesn't matter
but you know you kind of get into a flow
of like what's the best order to flip
your cards over I just start spamming
them but there's there used to be that
thing where you can kind of hover it and
yeah so you can see it blow bait spinner
okay it's gonna choose a death rattle
secretly I like that one that they don't
know what that death rattle is gonna be
and of course the Lich King kind of
focused on death so you expect some good
death effects so yeah I expect like I
think like roughly I think it's about
three ish legendaries per 50 packs
sometimes you know better or worse I
think you'll at least usually hope to
get about that many
it's always fun when a new expansion
comes out because you know there's all
these new cards to interact with kind of
just like an immune system and with the
death Knights to kind of learn and
figure out combo with and that's kind of
the beauty of hearthstone anything and
they're pretty smart they pretty much
drop expansions you know what like every
like yeah they finally got it into a
group they you have a schedule when this
stuff is gonna come out and of course
that lets you anticipate it the
interesting thing with this one I think
is that there's that single-player
mission which is free for everybody and
that and like I love the single players
it was fun with the previous expansions
that it felt like a bigger event but at
least with this one it's rigged so I
think that trolls more people like it
getting to earn more card packs from
that is such a smart move like that dad
engages people even more I said I wanted
these scientists I'm gonna get a lot of
dust at really good though combo give a
friendly minion poisonous it's a good
way to get rid of some big creatures and
the threatening board and it lets them
let you not necessarily get rid of a
poisonous because as soon as you see
that poisons on the board you know that
your opponent is gonna try to get rid of
that so that they can figure that friend
so far only one legendary of which you
know was kind of a guarantee in a way
it's been about 15 ish or so packs I've
been 16 now the hope in that he gets
better luck here because so far I think
it was like 182 epics and that legendary
so it hasn't been so great gonna go on
it's good amount of rares though oh
there you go as I as I say known for a
to remove the top card of your bull of
your opponent's dead that could be you
know it could be good part of a mill
deck potentially yeah yeah I mean if you
can get that battle trying to trigger
multiple times in some way
because on its own that's that's not
enough ooh golden let's look at it ooh
ice breaker a fun a fun weapon back in
the day when I used to you know play the
Wow you know I liked the bird somebody
good fun they have fun with it I mean
even the prologue was fun
oh there you go yeah nice sorrow I feel
back in the day I not that the game is
that old but I used to be more willing
to burn my golden parts just to get that
extra dust really but the more I play
the more I'd like to hold on it's all
about the it's all about the golden man
I remember I used to play magical on
when I was a kid actually just rummaged
up some parts but recently but when they
introduced foils there's like whole whoa
oils like foil cards this is kind of
insane you know and you want it to have
as many foil as if you kid in the deck
yeah the snow flip for penguin he's
super cute and worthless hey I wrote
most one one I've seen him combo didn't
some decks as a use for combo I compared
to some of the zero costs zero ones that
you get so two and only one legendary
not so hot golden Kong on it lifesteal
deal what do you think about this new
lifestyle like steel effect uh I mean
like it it's been around I mean like
it's it's gonna run another game yeah
other games I'm just saying like it's
been in a while right so I mean it makes
sense
oh the bear shark look at the head of
Golden Bear oh that's awesome I just
love this though cuz his junk like his
job alright the meat wagon they're
calling that the meme wagon apparently
because um yeah
yeah that's it that's an interesting
effect you can puff it like maybe yeah
that's the beauty of it oh here we go
oh okay so you got a Blood River golden
cool Dan grab sorry all friendly demons
that died this game that could be pretty
nasty so that's the Warlock that's not
hard right yeah awesome oh it's a good
one another meme wagon not bad though so
we got through you know see what else is
coming up have you uh I haven't opened
enough packs like the like this usually
spent my gold on like arena runs and
whatnot have you ever gotten that lucky
double legendary pack I've seen it like
a couple of times and it's got to feel
real good of course you know people
share that as soon as they get it it's
such a great feeling I really hope we
get it in this video because yeah oh
here we go
alright so frost Lich Jaina nice I
actually uh in playing the prologue that
effect seems pretty powerful I feel like
you know I play a lot of mage and it's a
lot there's a lot of frost bail so it
could be fun to combo it with her hero
ability which summons that three six
water elemental
so far so good
yeah that prologue is a little
misleading and how powerful it makes you
but it is a lot of fun they had fun with
the the story mode you know so and it's
it's a good time you know anything you
had a lot of those hey it's okay it's
all dust guys it's dust that's how you
got looking at us turn to dust
let's go epic another known for a tooth
dings yeah I mean I wonder if having all
the like the hero cards makes it harder
to get some of each other legendary like
the princes and the Lich King it's
probably you know golden eggs spreading
the plague that's a fun card I seen it
sometimes a 1:5 scare with taunt the
opponent has more minions casas again so
it cast as many you know hits as they
have hero powers are disabled that
[Music]
okay almost like Christmas
hey Criss Angel Mindfreak sorry I was
just in Vegas like he was like on a
billboard cause he was performing I
think I put Luxor you're always
guaranteed to be a rare but when it's
just a rare I don't know there's a
difference for me like there it's pretty
epic opening cards and hearthstone but
there's definitely a difference in like
picking your packs like at the store and
like opening like just a pack even
though you know like probably only one
round there sometimes it could be a
really good rare right but in this case
there's you know obviously more things
you could get black card that looks cool
whenever your hero is he'll deal that
much damage to a random enemy minion has
a lot of durability 3:9 although
paladin's don't have quite as many good
healing spaces Oh like that would be a
good play on hand holy light I don't
know if is holy I think holy light so
playable two four six play some you know
some creature bases healing as well
shadow blade I want to see the the
holographic version of that or the
animated version of the penguin oh here
we go
professor Petrus I'd put a random hunter
secret into the battlefield oh look at
that good really loving the animations
obviously ooh
seems like boat ride once you've um wow
that seems pretty good yeah it feels
like when things go well when you get
that legendary your other cards are also
elevated a little bit well cuz at that
point you're feeling good right so
everything else is a bonus so they've
also made a change so that you're not
gonna get more duplicates in one hand at
one draw then you can have in your deck
so you're not gonna get like four angry
chickens okay or something
but you could still get to we call that
earlier all right all right
about 37 inch packs in we've gotten I
think for legendary that's your third no
no more no more known for watching no
like no nos pronounced bra doesn't roll
off the tongue well 69 yep hopefully
like that that one's that one is pretty
crazy
cuz it's like gift charged and lifesteal
so you're gonna get that guaranteed 3
yeah but the voodoo hex errs seems
pretty crazy to you because it freezes
anything that damages and that he's able
to erase our 7jh yeah but I guess it's
quite nice some interesting and strong
cards as many of you guys are probably
seen already but we're going through
that's I feel like that's your third or
fourth roll the bones I mean it's gonna
happen when you have like hundred packs
but we've been kind of getting the same
epic - which is like you know that's so
lucky by at least because of the change
no legendary beat yet and you and I
think we've gotten four from the 40 or
so pack I think that's it's an air it's
something of course you can only do an
edge it's over okay but it it does make
you feel so much more confident about
her happy about getting a legendary that
you can you see that golden glow you
know it's gonna be something new all you
do now
yeah there's a time when it felt real
bad
to get duplication I don't think I felt
as bad as getting a duplicate legendary
as it did in overwatch though because
like mice my gripe with that was always
that you're only angry 200 gold for that
duplicate overwatch scan like and that's
less than a gold box of gold like a
legendary box of gold and later 200 is
like less than epic cost of a skin no
farhat - now it's finally something new
your end of turn fixed trigger twice I'm
sure there's some combos right it
doesn't new one for us and it feels like
you might need like 200 packs like that
everything or maybe you just have to
craft the rest of it that's what that's
what I tend to do like I'll for me
personally I'll tend to just buy the
Vindi I'll do that it's which is
spending so much money on a game like
this but uh I'll put down that money I
really like what they do with the game I
probably I wouldn't buy a hundred packs
on my own but the one I need a card I'll
go ahead and crap
I'm usually getting enough dust alright
and that big statue taunt lifesteal and
death rattle destroy it and so strong it
is a nine cost but worried durability
seen a lot of these healthy
right one to go no port yes yeah you've
done about 46 47 because he had 107
technically so far for alleged days some
came in kind of rapid succession oh
there's your burlock and he's golden
what's so chewy we're gone on a dry
spell for legendaries hopefully you got
the golden legendary golden letter and
you're much more than gambling then I am
too is this this fill you with
excitement
if daring cuz I'm not opening them you
know I'm hoping for the best for you
obviously but there's no you know I mean
it's not really gambling if you think
about it other than the fact that you
just don't know where you're getting
because at the end the day you get to
keep all the cards yeah but I mean
you're not gonna lose your money
no I already lost the money no more
you're not gonna earn money I'm not
getting anything
all right what do you got abominable
bull man do you know that's cool it's
like Pudge someone a random friendly
beast that died in this game
I think it's an effect we've seen quite
it quite a bit or that kind of effect is
something I'm digging the hunter
we've gotten some decent you know
Golden's even though some have in common
but you know some of those are have been
pretty cool like the borough law a
little doge I think I'm probably gonna
have to go for the death knight hunter
card now yeah if I don't get it that was
but that's pretty cool card yeah cuz
that ability is pretty good it was like
the build of monster build oh yeah
hopefully to get it I mean if that's I
think before we started this recording
you're telling me you know it'd be nice
to get a prince or more than Prince
maybe Lich King but I think really great
to see what that's the whole theme
around the deck you just want to be able
to add that to your hand or tier to your
collection halfway like I said you've
gotten four in about
like fifty something close to sixty
which is about on par which is why I
said right which is about 350 and they
got the first one within the first panel
so if you're lucky you'll get another
forest of which hopefully one is the
hunter hero a hunter at night
golden rare doomed apprentice it's kind
of like the opposite of The Sorcerer's
Apprentice so we played very differently
you do a lot of arena and I tend to play
ranked and tavern brawl yeah so are you
as excited about these new expansions as
they come out yeah because I mean it
still changes the game you know in arena
even it's more fun for me because it's
it's more like drafting like a magic
where you get to pick from certain sets
of cards you know three at a time and
kind of compete against other people
that have similar experience now
granting some people will get more
legendaries or more epics have better
decks but usually oh you get it's a
balanced match they usually try to
balance you based and matchmaking you
against people that are like kind of
around the same win wins and losses so I
don't know it's just a different dynamic
I don't play as much constructed because
I ultimately don't buy packs and it's
sometimes hard to compete and
constructed once you get to a certain
level without having better car with you
and to get better cards unity to
Bailey's and play a lot or buy cards and
so to me arena is a shorter kind of
quicker experience that's like gambling
if anything because you're spending that
150 gold to hope that you have a good 5
plus win run you know hopefully you get
to 1012 win and you'll reap the benefits
but you could also do really poorly you
know and then you might lose out on some
of the cost you spent so that's an
interesting effect for overload
cost one less for each mana crystal
usually more rare kind of in that same
giant like vein though it's cool - sorry
but not really and we're really getting
them bear shard but the beer oh here we
go
Blood Queen atlanna feel like I still
has plus one attack for each card you've
discarded this game that could be really
big wrong warlock card potentially
pretty good so so far about five
Legendary's which is pretty cool
still nothing that you particularly
wanted and so hopefully you get one of
those in the next four you go look at
another 40 there's a look there's still
a lot of chances to get this stuff I'm
looking for this is how they get you
though you don't get what you want the
best cards are always the one you don't
have in your deck happy ghoul so happy
even though he is it that seems pretty
good cause 0 if your hero was healed
this turn and all classes
III give me a free three three all right
what do we got no really I have too many
hard I think or like a viable card but
he's not stacking it's not like they get
more powerful the more I find got enough
scientist here need some need some
Prince's o gold you already have one of
those but now having to to rent two of
those golden pair short can your
shortage spills a very common card yeah
that in the plague scientists we got a
lot of the leeching poison I feel like
we've got to have gotten all the commons
by now or something because like I see a
lot of the same ones Alf beam comes up a
lot
roll the bones comes up a lot and
burlock
we got too many parts should've gotten
less I would've been happier do you
think so oh that's new discard all
weapons from your hand and game they're
set that could be beast
we got new cards a little loyalty need
like a hunter hero legendary please that
seems to you too corpse widow I don't
think I've seen that one yet
from her for us but 36 to go I say you
probably get at least one more legendary
maybe two if you're lucky that would be
the dream probably yeah probably be
outside that one's pretty good eternal
sir yeah I've done so this is these are
my first cards so this will be my chance
to actually draft a lich king or okay I
mean create Frozen Throne yeah or like a
combo hybrid with frozen throne cards
which is usually the case or you could
just make sure it's viable for like a
little bit depending on what rank here
at that seems you to exploding bloke
that dead man's hand shuffle a copy of
your hand into your deck okay I was I've
seen interesting effects with that one
when Blizzard themselves at a strange
here we go come on okay double rare it's
a good start gonna triple rare no epic
how's it destroy a friendly minion
destroy choose a friendly minion minion
destroy it and a random there's such
good names to unwilling sacrifice a grim
necromancer
don't let sanguine let's go event so
according to the rules that usually I'll
be able to get another that's too bad
what is a golden penguin I hope that
looks creepy
destroy all 1-cos spells in both hands
and decks I've seen this and that I'd
like so this is like deadly to like the
shapeshifter like the card from the last
expansion that turns all of your cards
into the the one cost shakes
shapeshifter against certain metas he is
deadly by himself
golden rare druid of this war so
transforming to one to poisonous or a
1/5 of time so it's one of those snails
yeah or 100
love the snails oh the snails come in
cylinder so he - Donovan can't remember
the name I I always Draft at least one
though because it's so annoying to deal
with oh we got
Haeju knocks death rattle some of your
taunt minions that died this game seems
like more of a they're a lot yeah
exactly I was thinking warrior but yeah
I guess you know you went taunt for a
lot of your choose ones yeah there's
some some of those transformer fire joy
so far six legendaries getting a lot of
these unborn belches the other common
man Oh
epic dead man's hand your second one I
want to see a golden version a dead
man's hands pretty nice effect those
zombies I filled his crushed spirit as
he opens the remainder of his packs
knowing he hasn't gotten what he wanted
and that's you realize the salt that is
how would he do are you a lot of how
many we got this place is that the pilot
double-digit bear sharks probably but at
least we have a golden bear shark that's
what matters then a golden play dad -
arrogant Crusader I think a play on
argent Crusader
yeah what's gonna have to you somebody
Attica about a quarter of your packs
left sans those extra seven man big
money big money that's not money that's
not a big blending either you're just
trying to hold out hope here you kind of
milk it we've gotten a lot of shadow
plays like on the on the brighter note
the way you should look at it is you're
gonna have a lot better man you got a
lot of gold yeah you got a lot of gold I
just realized I'm always very low
because I just arena run and sometimes I
don't do very well so I don't get my
return back I do my daily it's pretty
not religiously but at least I try to
clear it out twice a week someone to it
oh they're poisonous at least I guess
that's pretty nice he's expensive for a
cost yeah if you could you could have
played the that other drew Carter we
just got that you could either pick a
one two or the one five and there was a
to cost it would be cheaper to play two
of those in man sure I see why that's it
but maybe that saves a little bit of
spacing on Jack so you don't have to
play that card the other cards
that one yeah give your company unless
to cluster I named it's what's two plus
zero plus two plus three even got a
couple of those so far pretty mediocre
I'd say yeah I think you're gonna get
one more legendary though I feel it I'm
feeling it man I feel like I have to get
at least I'm not gonna get a double edge
babe I don't feel that Wow I just don't
feel it oh well we got black card that's
my second point so now you have two of
those
another area at C course you gotta have
a whole army away just to be a penguin
double rare let me stick though forget
the double edges okay I'm rooting for
you man epic is good another woman a
Bombo man nope third one of those like I
said man at least you're gonna have a
lot of dust so you can make that hunter
card if you need to gotta see where the
bet is going what's that what's the new
rush deck that I have to make a lead be
like some tires crazy pirate stuff and I
was like what's going on here how's he
doing pirates
dude it'd be nice if you got sindragosa
yeah that'd be sweet yeah so it's
interesting that the the single player
doesn't reward two specific cards from
the previous single-player missions
after you beat them you would get like
very slow and this time beating them
just get your packs yeah I'd rather take
the pack it's more fun that way to
chance it well more fun and more salt
depending on how you look at it I like
knowing what I get I guess that's -
another rare golden golden rare
desperate to stand it yeah all right
eleven packs or twelve packs ago willing
to get a legendary and one that he wants
or a double legendary get super lucky
ice Walker
I saw them at Game of Thrones are you
sure oh yeah sure I'm pretty sure
they're common animals did you have the
vision
I'm the three-eyed Raven the four-eyed
Raven it's not looking good ladies and
gentlemen I mean I I don't know the
power cards yet I know Lich Kings a
pretty good one so I'm it's hard for me
to say if what Justin's got gotten so
far has been great legendary wise but
maybe you guys to chime in in the
comments below if he's got lucky or if
he's just gotten does no epic epic epic
that's special villager combo deal
damage equal to the number of other
cards you've played this turn rogue has
a lot of synergy lately a lot of low
costing and stuff
what more rare nice if your opponent's
turn eight-pack Kobe hook us up Kobe
and never did like Kobe another read
over here all right purple one of those
Oh double epic golden epic look at that
bring it on alright camera reduces the
closet in your opponent's hand by two
though geez that's a risky one yeah but
if you're if you're confident if you
know like you you have lethal really
soon I don't know that what do you do is
I'm gonna stall right now looks though
or if you have something like you've
know you're playing a rush deck you gets
a turn eight like play that there's not
much else are gonna be able to do like
sure they can play it like they're out
of cards play it budget cut I know I'm
sure I'm sure works out I'm sure it's
gonna be a double rare that's not what
we're looking for here Blizzard and
we're looking for a legendary and these
five packs just shake the good one so
that looks a little yeah Sparkle
a lot of plague scientists fire armor
I'm not feeling uh lucky I thought you'd
get one more oh it's pretty sure about
it here we go Lord all right two more
you see it's because of your negative
energy oh you think it's my fault your
negativity is bringing down no enemy
under the bus got it stay in the salt
wine is just good start
it's a rare nothing really really ending
with a plague scientists what o7 packs
you get I believe I have marked Brook I
think there's a six
legendaries so basically you're on like
a 1 per like 20-ish you know better than
that ratio so there's the Hadrian ops
that was new what about if you just got
rid of all your dupes has to go ahead
and a lot doesn't chance some extras
yeah see yeah but um holiness yeah that
was a look at 107 pax6 legendaries you
guys can tell us again in the comments
below if you thought we got some good
ones or if it was as mediocre as I
thought it was I'm sorry just kind of
like my ranking video well candy life
yeah life too but make sure you guys
subscribe on YouTube and give us a like
because you know that always helps us
for more continuing coverage of
hearthstone and all Blizzard games alike
thanks guys